Before their deaths, the following actors
didn't just make their marks as some of Marvel's
most popular or interesting characters.
They left behind impressive bodies of work,
with Hollywood being all the better for their contributions.
These stars weren't just Marvel favorites,
they built some of Hollywood's most distinguished careers.
Miguel Ferrer comes from a major show business
family.
His cousin was superstar George Clooney and
his parents were Oscar-winner Jose Ferrer
and '50s pop star Rosemary Clooney.
David Lynch fans remember Ferrer as the opinionated
FBI agent Albert Rosenfield on Twin Peaks.
Ferrer also co-starred in the 1994 adaptation
of Stephen King's The Stand, playing Randall
Flagg's right-hand man, Lloyd Henreid.
Apart from his dozens of other TV guest star
roles, Ferrer made memorable appearances in
films including Traffic, Hot Shots: Part Deux,
and RoboCop.
But observant Marvel Cinematic Universe fans
will remember him for his brief but important
part in Iron Man 3.
In the final entry of the trilogy, Ferrer
played Rodriguez, the corrupt, Mandarin-connected
vice president of the United States who tries
to help assassinate President Matthew Ellis.
Sadly, in January 2017, Ferrer died of cancer-related
complications at the age of 61.
When stand-up comedy boomed in the 1980s and
early 1990s, tons of clubs popped up in cities,
cable networks filled out their programming
day with shows like An Evening at the Improv
and The HBO Comedy Half-Hour, and a ton of
joke-tellers became instantly famous.
Among them was John Pinette, a gifted stand-up
and impressionist.
Pinette dedicated a lot of his act to making
fun of himself.
He toured and taped comedy specials extensively
while also landing acting roles.
After playing a high school coach on Parker
Lewis Can't Lose, he appeared on Seinfeld,
Dr. Katz: Professional Therapist, and in 2004,
he showed up as Bumpo in the ultra-violent
film adaptation of the ultra-violent revenge
comic The Punisher, opposite Thomas Jane.
Pinette brought comic relief to the otherwise
dark movie as the easy-going character and
the financial beneficiary of the Punisher's
crusade.
Tragically, in 2014, Pinette was found dead
in a Pittsburgh hotel room, and a medical
examiner ruled that he'd passed as a result
of natural causes.
Pinette was only 50.
In 1969, Peter Fonda produced and starred
in the hippie and counterculture classic biker
movie Easy Rider, for which he received his
first of two Academy Award nominations.
The second came for 1997's Ulee's Gold, in
which Fonda starred as a grieving beekeeper
with a troubled family.
In between, Fonda appeared in dozens of well-known
movies, including The Last Movie, The Cannonball
Run, and Escape from L.A.
Fonda's role in Ghost Rider as Mephistopheles
was among the last in a long, legendary career.
"Far out."
In 2007, actor and avid comic book fan Nick
Cage got his superhero franchise going with
two Ghost Rider movies.
Cage played Johnny Blaze, a bounty hunter
forced into service for the unholy demon played by Fonda.
In 2019, Fonda passed away at age 79 due to
lung cancer.
Just before 2010, Irrfan Khan got acting gigs
in popular and acclaimed American and British films.
He played a police detective in the Oscar-nominated
Slumdog Millionaire, and he portrayed the
adult version of main character Pi Patel,
recalling his survival of a shipwreck, in
the Oscar-nominated Life of Pi.
Khan showed up as dinosaur park owner Simon
Masrani in Jurassic World and he also played
the villainous Provost in Inferno.
Fans of Andrew Garflield's Peter Parker will
also recognize Khan from The Amazing Spider-Man,
where he played Oscorp executive and scientist
Dr. Rajit Ratha.
As a prolific television actor, Khan broke
through to the A-list of Indian cinema in
the 2000s and won numerous accolades for his
work in Life in a Metro, Haasil, and Paan
Singh Tomar, which won him a National Film
Award for Best Actor.
Shockingly, in 2018, Khan announced that he'd
been diagnosed with a neuroendocrine tumor.
Following a hospitalization in Mumbai for
an infection in 2020, the superstar died at age 53.
In 2008, Iron Man became the first Marvel
Cinematic Universe entry.
But the modern history of movies based on
Marvel Comics characters goes back to 1986,
with the critically reviled box office flop,
Howard the Duck.
Protagonist Howard is involved in everything
sci-fi, including the Cosmos itself, personified
and voiced by veteran actor Richard Kiley.
"The cosmos.
Countless worlds upon worlds."
Kiley was a decorated actor, appearing in
shows like Hawaii Five-O and Columbo and won
four Emmy Awards and two Tony Awards, including
one for Man of La Mancha.
Kiley died in march 1999 of a blood disorder.
He was 76 years old.
As one of film and TV's most prolific, intense,
and versatile character actors, it's hard
to say exactly which role is the one for which
Reg E. Cathey is best known.
It might be warden Martin Querns on the harrowing
prison drama Oz, or political organizer Norman
Wilson on The Wire, or barbecue joint proprietor
Freddy Hayes on House of Cards, which won
Cathey an Emmy Award for Outstanding Guest
Actor in a Drama Series.
Cathey also played more than one role in multiple
Marvel franchises.
In the 2015 Fantastic Four reboot, he portrayed
Dr. Franklin Storm, father of superheroes
Sue and Johnny Storm.
Cathey also starred in Netflix Marvel Cinematic
Universe-adjacent series Luke Cage, in the
role of James Lucas, a pastor and the father
of Luke.
In February 2018, Cathey died at his New York
City home from lung cancer, according to the New York Times.
Cathey was 59.
Dr. Wesley Von Spears appeared briefly in
both Guardians of the Galaxy films.
He didn't have any lines, but he was memorable
just the same, because Von Spears is a dog.
In Guardians of the Galaxy, the pup portrayed
"Holographic Dog," and in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 2 he played the part of "Dog in
the Back of Truck at Dairy Queen."
Landing a role in Hollywood is sometimes about
who you know, and nepotism definitely played
a part in Von Spears' casting since he was
the pet of Guardians writer-director James
Gunn.
The dog's influence on Marvel movies comprises
more than just a couple of cameos.
Gunn told i09:
"Truthfully, a lot of Groot is based on my
dog Von Spears.
I think there's a sort of puppy-like innocence
to Groot.
That if my dog could talk, it would probably
say, 'I am Groot.'"
Dr. Wesley Von Spears died at age 17 in February
2020.
Gunn briefly delayed filming on his next film,
The Suicide Squad, to fly home and be with
his dog in his final moments.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.